two presidents and one Prime Minister
came to Strasbourg this week President
of Colombia Juan Manuel Santos and the
president of Guinea Alpha Conde
addressed Parliament while Luxembourg's
Prime Minister Sevilla Battelle debated
the future of Europe with members in
2015 there were two million posted
workers in the EU members voted in new
rules to ensure that these workers get
equal pay for equal work households can
save up to four hundred and ninety euros
on energy bills each year thanks to the
e use eco design directive it means that
manufacturers have to meet energy
requirements when designing their
products Parliament called for
improvements to the current policy
members debated the multi-annual
financial framework the e used next
long-term budget for after 2020 they
call for the research and innovation
budget to be increased by at least 50%
the EU accounts for around 15% of world
trade in goods Parliament adopted
legislation to protect EU trade by
tackling dumped and subsidized imports
from third countries